Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Der muss ja eigentlich selber machen. Also ich meine, wenn du so ein Problem hast und zum Datenschutzbeauftragten gehst, dann wird er natürlich auch auf beine Hilfe zurückgreifen und sagen, dann zeig mir das doch mal und das dann auf einen offiziellen Weg machen. Das heißt, er muss das nicht unbedingt verstehen. Er muss das grundsätzlich sehen, was das Problem ist. Aber er muss das nicht mit den Finessen des Proxys vertraut sein.
Ich glaube, man sieht hier einfach auch, dass da mehr nötig ist als eine Gesetzesänderung. Das heißt, wir brauchen auch ein Umdenken. Denn was du beschreibst, dass es gang und gäbe ist und dass es sowieso keine Peilung hat, weil viel zu tun hat und viel zu viele IT-Systeme da sind, da muss man halt auch echt in der Struktur arbeiten. Und aber auch ein bisschen an der Wahrnehmung davon, was man sich irgendwie noch vorstellen kann, ob man tut. Das ist so ein bisschen so ein Umdenken, wo ich glaube, da brauchen wir halt noch eine ganze Zeit, bis das verstanden ist.
Ich will einfach nur sagen, dass es sehr viele schöne Gesetze gibt, aber keiner so richtig prüft, inwieweit sie praxisrelevant sind. Bei diesem Gesetz ist der Denkansatz klasse, aber die Umsetzung ist sehr kompliziert. Und sie würde wirklich bedeuten, dass sich Personal aufbläht, und es ist ein teurer Spaß auch. Deswegen muss man einfach sagen, okay, wir kennen die Regeln, und wir verhalten uns entsprechend. Ansonsten kann es ein bisschen böse aussehen.
Und wenn ihr, um auf deinen Fall zurückzukommen, wenn ihr das Gefühl habt, dass bei euch in der Firma ein Whistleblower ist, dann tut manchmal vielleicht auch ein kollegales Gespräch schon... Ja, das kommt sowieso.
Aber ich habe diese Sendung gehört, auch bei den Kraftfahrern. Das hatte ich ja vorher. Da hatte ich auch so ein System, wo man einen Kraftfahrer per GPS überwacht. Und da war auch die Diskussion, was ist denn mit dieser Teil sowieso? Ja, kann man ja ganz genau sehen, der ist von A nach B gefahren, da war mal kurz im Baumarkt, hat mal einen kurzen Blick geworfen, weil er ein bisschen Laminat brauchte, und die wollten das nicht. Und ja, es war gar nicht so einfach, das so einzutakten, dass eben der Chef das nicht machen kann. Ja, gab es sehr viele Diskussionen, und am Ende hat es dann doch gekonnt, aber okay, da war dann so ein Gentleman-Decrement. Aber ich muss schon sagen, dass das bei den Kraftfahrern auch sehr, sehr schwer umzusetzen geht. Die werden ja auch getrieben, und mit acht Stunden ist da alles Illusion. Wir haben hier einen Preiskampf, da kommen Leute aus allen Jahren lindern.
Da komme ich jetzt mal um die Ecke und sage, Max, das ist schon wieder ein anderes Thema.
Durch diese Möglichkeiten, die neue Technik, kann man eigentlich die Leute immer weiter auskundschaften. Man hat im Lesen eine Bürgerwache, das ist einfach.
Lassen wir genauso stehen. Max, danke dir für den Anruf.
Ich danke auch.
Die Zeitsprechstunden.
Die Young Lovers sind das Shake the Ghost, Chaos Radio auf Fritz Nummer 143, trägt den schönen Titel, Belauscht, Bespitzelt, Abgeschnorchelt, Datenschutz für Arbeitnehmer, der Chaos Computer Club ist zu Gast bei Fritz, Constanze und Starbucks sind da, mein Name ist Jakob Kranz, ihr seid eingeladen anzurufen unter 0331 77 97 1 2 0 und von euren Geschichten, von eurer Arbeit oder von eurer Uni oder von euren Bewerbungen zu erzählen. Der nächste am Telefon ist Rainer, du musst jetzt ein bisschen warten, ich hoffe das ist nicht so schlimm, Name Rainer. Wo arbeitest du, wie ist es bei dir?
Ich bin im Moment nicht berufstätig und es ist noch mal eine Aussage dazu, dass es ja schon von dem Administrator angesprochen worden ist, die Gesetze erfunden wurden am grünen Tisch und praktikabel mit mehr, meistens nur mit mehr Personal und noch mehr Überwachung. Irgendwann wir überwachtigen Überwacher. Und wir hatten ja vor kurzem noch, die ging durch die Medien, dass eine Kassiererin bei Kaisers für 1, 30 Euro den Arbeitsplatz verloren hat. Im Arbeitsgericht in der zweiten Kasserserie. Und auch da wird ja überwacht, bzw. die Frage ist, die Tendenz oder alles, das wird national überwacht und das wird in der EG überwacht. Von der EG war mit eurem Mann in einer Telefonannahme, dass in Finnland jetzt noch oder jetzt wieder zusätzlich die E-Mails überwacht werden. Das ist glaube ich noch ein Zusatz von der EG oder Nachschlag geworden, dass jeweils die E-Mails auch noch mit überwacht werden sollen. Und die Frage ist eigentlich...
Meinst du Vorratsdatenspeicherung oder was meinst du?
Na, weiter also Vorratsdatenspeicherung oder Überwachung, ja.
Na ja, du meinst die sogenannte Telekom-Paket.
Und bei allen großen Firmen ist in der letzten Zeit hochgekommen, dass das Personal überwacht wird. Und die Frage ist, wenn dort in Deutschland keine geklärte Rechtslage ist, dann ist eigentlich der Vorstoß von den Arbeitgebern mit meinem Rechtsverständnis eigentlich eine strafbare Handlung. Weil sie arbeiten da im rechtsfreien Raum.
Also das ist tatsächlich für einige der großen Skandale vom letzten Jahr der Fall. Da ermitteln ja auch die Staatsanwaltschaften, ist keine Frage. Aber da sind natürlich auch ein paar Bereiche, die man so als Grauzone bezeichnen kann. Und dann gibt es halt ein paar Bereiche, zum Beispiel bei der Bahn, wo sie ja immer viel mit dieser Korruptionsbekämpfung argumentieren, die eigentlich überhaupt nicht vom Unternehmen so global gemacht werden muss. Und natürlich vom Staat, denn der Staat ist ja eigentlich der Korruptionsbekämpfer.
Da gibt es ja eigene Vereinten und Organisationen, die sich darum kümmern.
Genau, also dann sagen sie halt, wir haben ja auch 17 Leute gefangen, bei unserem eben tausendfachen Datenabgleich. Damit ist das ja ausreichend begründet. Also da wird dann ganz klar dagegen verstoßen, was Rechtslage ist. Aber eben für den einzelnen Arbeitnehmer ist das ja schwer zu überblicken. Ich habe ja vorhin mal gesagt, wie viele Gesetze man dafür kennen muss, plus die Gerichtsentscheidung. Das ist ja grad, warum er halt echt gefordert werden muss. Da brauchen wir jetzt mal klare und zwar restriktive Regeln, damit die Arbeitgeber nicht meinen, das wird jetzt hier so usus, wie das 2008 in den Medien war.
Also um Rainers Argument noch mal aufzugreifen, wer überwacht eigentlich die, die die anderen überwachen? Wir hatten gerade die Wortmeldung, dass die Datenschutzbeauftragten in den Firmen eigentlich überlastet sind, weil viel zu viel Arbeitsvolumen und viel zu viel Fach- und Detailkenntnis auf viel zu wenig Leute umgewälzt wird. Beziehungsweise, dass die Rechtslage, die im Moment besteht, undurchsichtig ist, weil es die verschiedensten Gesetze gibt und weil keiner so richtig blickt, nach welchen Richtlinien man jetzt quasi sein Unternehmen schützen kann, wenn man kontrolliert, was da passiert und wo es dann quasi in den illegalen Bereich geht. Also, wo ist denn jetzt die Instanz? Oder welche Instanz wäre denn zuständig, um sich darum zu kümmern? Außer wieder ein paar Internetausdrucker, die den Gesetze entlassen.
Also ich glaube, die Instanz ist halt irgendwie schon ganz klar. Das sind halt die Datenschützer. Also beziehungsweise die Datenschutzbeauftragte, die im Betrieb oder die Landes- oder Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragten sind. Das Problem ist halt einfach, auch mehrfach schon angesprochen heute, dass sie halt personell halt so unterbesetzt sind. Also auch gerade die Landes- und Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragten, die haben halt wirklich 10, 20, 30 Leute. Also irgendwie halt so geringe Anzahl, dass sie sich halt maximal mit ein paar hundert Fällen im Jahr überhaupt befassen können. Also auch gerade, wenn man irgendwie ja sieht, was das für ein Volumen ist. Das heißt eigentlich muss da ganz klar sein, irgendwie die brauchen mehr Personal und wie auch klare Regelungen, um halt irgendwie solche Fälle halt einfach mal auch schnell abzuarbeiten zu können.
Es gibt natürlich eine zweite Instanz. Das wäre natürlich klassischerweise, man geht zum Anwalt, wenn man also weiß, mein Arbeitgeber hat diese oder jene grenzlegale oder illegale Überwachungsmaßnahmen gegen mich unternommen, kann man machen. Aber wir haben halt auch gesehen, dass viele, der zumindest sehr ans Licht gekommen ist, Skandale, so prekäre Arbeitsverhältnisse betreffen. Die Kassiererin von Lidl oder von Rewe wird sich selten sofort zum Anwalt begeben, weil das ist halt auch eine teure Sache. Wenn man jetzt etwa so hat, weiß ich nicht, sagen wir mal, Mobiltelefonüberwachung bei mittleren Angestellten, okay, die gehen vielleicht noch zum Anwalt. Das ist natürlich auch eine Option. Aber wir wünschten uns halt auch, und das ist eine ganz klare Forderung, auch schon seit Jahren, dass a. die Aufstattung besser wird, aber b. man auch konkrete Ansprechpartner hat in den Landesdatenschutzbehörden, wo man eben, da gibt es halt eine Nummer, da kann ich anrufen, da ist ein, zwei, drei Mitarbeiter, die sich um sowas kümmern, und zwar im Zweifel auch anonym, wenn ich halt Angst in meinem Job habe.
Also, ich würde das auf jeden Fall erstmal annehmen und irgendwie dann das weiterverfolgen. Also, genau das, was halt vorhin schon angesprochen wurde, die müssen sich halt gar nicht irgendwie mit der Materie sehr zu genau auskennen, sie müssen halt einfach wissen, dass es halt irgendwie dort ein Problem gibt und halt im Zweifel dann dann einfach mal nachforschen.
Also von offiziellerer Seite einfach Druck machen.
Es kommt halt einfach viel besser, wenn halt der Landesdatenschutzbeauftragte irgendwie dann mal eine Abordnung in den Betrieb schickt und mal irgendwie fragt, also wir haben hier gehört irgendwie und können Sie mal da Zustellung nehmen. Weil die Arbeitgeber verpflichtet sind, irgendwie dann auch wirklich zu antworten und irgendwie dann die Details rauszulassen.
Und die dritte Instanz, die man da noch dazu rechnen muss, sind natürlich die Betriebsräte. Zwar sind die, wenn man einen betrieblichen Datenschutzbeauftragten hat, nicht die so direkt zuständig, aber über die Mitbestimmungsrechte sind sie fast immer dabei. Wenn also neue Datenverarbeitungssysteme eingesetzt werden, eine neue Personaldatenverarbeitung, alles sowas, dann sind die natürlich drin und bestimmen auch die Betriebsvereinbarungen mit. Das heißt, auch da ist es so, dass wir natürlich eine Stärkung brauchen.
Vor allem auch wenn dann halt wirklich Überwachungsmaßnahmen durchgeführt werden, dann sind also wirklich, wenn diese, wenn die Maßnahmen durchgeführt werden, sind die Auftragte überverpflichtet, die Betriebsräte zu informieren, dass es stattfindet und die müssen es im Allgemeinen halt auch abnicken dann.
Das klingt unterm Strich wie ein großes Feld der Neueinstellung, der zu schaffenden Berufe. Bewerbt euch alle als Datenschutzbeauftragte. Da gibt es Arbeit ohne...
Man muss auch einige Fähigkeiten mit sich bringen. Also es gibt doch schon ein paar Anforderungen.
Ist schon klar, aber der Bedarf ist auf jeden Fall da und er kann. Rainer, danke dir für deinen Anruf. Chaosradio, hört ihr auf Fritz? 0331 70 97 110 ist unsere Telefonnummer. Der nächste am Telefon ist Andreas aus Aachen. Guten Abend, Andreas. Grüß dich. Ihr seid doch in Aachen gerade in der absoluten Karnevals, im Karnevalswahnsinn, ertrunken, oder?
Ja, ich bin da sozusagen Karnevalsflüchtling gewesen. Ich hab mich in eine ruhige Region zurückgezogen.
Und ab morgen, ab Donnerstag sind die ersten Geschäfte uns wieder ansprechbar, weil heute bis Aschermittwoch alle gefeiert haben.
Ja, ne, das lief doch heute schon wieder relativ normal.
Okay, wir sehen also rosigen Zeiten entgegen der Karnevals durch. Was ist dein Begehr?
Ja, also ich hab die Frage, wenn man sich z.B. beruflich umorientieren möchte, wird man ja häufig aufgefordert, seine Bewerbungsunterlagen per PDF einzureichen. Und ja, ich hab ja immer ein etwas ungutes Gefühl, weil ich nicht weiß, was mit diesen Dateien halt im Nachhinein passiert. Werden die zentral gespeichert? Die sind dann ja im Prinzip jahrelang noch wieder aufrufbar. Und ja, ich hab mir schon mal überlegt, ob man nicht jetzt zum Beispiel so eine PDF-Datei, die kann man im Prinzip verschlüsseln, ob man dann nicht auch dann sozusagen auf einem Server, den dann derjenige das einsehen möchte, kontaktieren muss, dann sozusagen Zertifikatsabgleich macht, dass das nur ein, zwei Monate abrufbar ist, diese Datei und danach halt, ja.
Und dann kommt die Personalabteilung und sagt, ich versteh das nicht, schicken sie es mir bitte her, weil ansonsten guck ich es gar nicht erst an.
Das klingt alles schön, aber halt genauso Daten. Also wenn du sie halt einmal anzeigen kannst auf dem Bildschirm, dann hast du sie halt auch für ewig irgendwie gespeichert. Das hat das Problem an digitalen Sachen, aber es ist eine sehr interessante Frage, wie man halt mit so Daten umgeht, beziehungsweise so Löschungsfristen, beziehungsweise einfach, wie löst man überhaupt wirklich Daten?
Ja, oder habe ich das Recht zum Beispiel, das ist ja dann vielleicht nicht mein zukünftiger Arbeitgeber, das heißt, ich habe da keine rechtliche Beziehung zu dem, habe dem aber mal meine Daten geschickt, habe ich da irgendwie das Recht dann zu verlangen, dass die wirklich gelöscht werden, habe ich ein Nachprüfrecht, ob das wirklich geschehen ist.
Also du hast das Recht, irgendwie jedem, der Daten über dich speichert, irgendwie zu fragen, welche Daten er über dich speichert und es im Zweifelsfall irgendwie auch löschen zu lassen. Du kannst natürlich nicht wirklich überprüfen, das ist das Problem. Aber zumindest rein rechtlich bist du dazu berechtigt, das abzufragen und irgendwie auch die Löschung in Auftrag zu geben.
Genau, also du könntest bei der Firma, bei der du dich beworben hast, die dich da nicht genommen haben, könntest du denen einen Brief oder eine Mail schreiben und kannst darum bitten, dass deine Daten gelöscht werden.
Genau, bei Papierformen bekommt man ja dann eben seine Unterlage zurück.
Genau, oder sie fragen dich, ist es okay, wenn wir die überhalten?
Genau.
So wird das mit der Mail genauso laufen. Kannst du dich dann hinwenden, kannst du sagen, bitte weg.
Bei den Papierdatengut könnten sie natürlich auch kopieren, aber das ist zum Beispiel nicht möglich, dann solche Daten eben irgendwie mal informell weiterzuschicken.
Na gut, aber das ist natürlich auch einfach möglich. Ich weiß, auf dem Scanner habe ich auch eine Mail. Aber der Aufwand ist halt weit größer, klar.
Mir ist immer ein bestimmtes Unbehagen, wenn ich sowas dann los schicken soll. Ich würde es am liebsten immer noch per Papier machen, aber dann gucken die Leute es sich manchmal vielleicht gar nicht an, weil es so umständlich ist und sie wollen das halt auf dem Rechner am Platz haben und fertig aus, dann bin ich halt gezwungen, das halt auch auf diese Weise in die Welt zu schicken.
Ja, noch schlimmer ist es eigentlich, wenn man eben diese sogenannten freiwilligen Tests macht, also Drogentests, Gentests mittlerweile, also dass man alles mögliche, was machen dann eigentlich die Unternehmen nachher damit. Wir haben eigentlich so ein bisschen, das geht ein bisschen über den Arbeitnehmerdatenschutz hinaus, wir haben halt auch eine Idee, wie man da dem normalen Bürger, nicht nur Bewerber, sondern im Prinzip jedem Menschen, da so ein bisschen die Macht zurückkippt. Wir haben seit einiger Zeit über diese Idee des Datenbriefes nachgedacht. Der Datenbrief soll halt ein Dokument sein, was man einmal im Jahr bekommt, und zwar von all denen, die meine Daten verarbeiten. Das sind natürlich dann so einige Briefe bei erwachsenen Menschen, die ein Bankkonto haben. Aber man könnte die halt gleichzeitig zusammen mit Vertragsunterlagen oder eben mit Werbung, die man ja ohnehin bekommt.
Wo du eine Übersicht hast über die Dinge, die gespeichert sind.
Das hat genau das, was du halt gerade angefragt hast, von der anderen Seite aufgezogen, dass jeder verpflichtet ist, per Gesetz genau zu schreiben, wenn er Daten über dich hat, und halt auch genau zu sagen, welche, und im Zweifel auch irgendwie mit dem Ankreuzbriefchen irgendwie, ich soll die Daten irgendwie erzöschen.
Ich hab schon mal den Trick gemacht, wenn ich irgendwo meine Daten zu Werbezwecken, die ich also speziell anfordere, dann angeben muss, dass ich dann irgendwie noch einen zweiten Vornamen zurückgehe. Und dann weiß ich halt, wo die herkommen. Und dann kann ich denen entsprechend, wenn es dann da kommt, anhauen, warum hast du meine Daten weitergegeben.
Na gut, aber hast du das schon mal getan? Oder hast du das schon mal aufgetreten?
Nee, ist noch nicht aufgetreten. Aber wie gesagt, ich habe dann eben von der Firma, wo ich dann direkt das erste Mal angefordert habe, habe ich dann halt mir so eine Notiz gemacht, wer das eben mit diesem entsprechenden Kürzel hat. Und wenn da eben was käme, also bis jetzt habe ich Glück gehabt, weil ich das auch sehr selten halt mache und nicht jedem meine Daten halt gebe und was anfordere. Und auch eigentlich meistens an für mich vertrauenswürdige Stellen. Aber wenn eben so was passieren würde, habe ich halt die Möglichkeit, das dann nachzuvollziehen.
Was war es genau denn deine Befürchtung? Also wenn es halt so um Bewerbungsunterlagen geht, warum willst du denn nicht, dass dein Arbeitgeber oder dein Nicht-Arbeitgeber irgendwie noch Daten über dich hat, die du ihm mal gegeben hast?
Ja, ich habe es schon mal so auf weiter Ferne gehört von Bekannten, dass dann mal schnell, wenn irgendwie ein Bewerber zum Beispiel zum Vorstellungsgespräch kommt, dass er dann halt mal schnell die Bewerbungsdaten nochmal eben irgendwo rüber geschickt werden. Es könnte natürlich jetzt sein, dass jemand irgendwie, der mir nicht gut will, meine Bewerbung, die ich irgendwo hinschicke, irgendjemandem schickt, bei dem ich noch in Arbeit bin zum Beispiel, guckt mal an und dann entweder um mich da rauszuhauen oder was weiß ich. Man könnte ja mit diesen Daten, wenn man jetzt erfährt, ich schaue mich um, ich bin noch in der Beschäftigung, könnte das natürlich irgendwo wieder ankommen.
Beziehungsweise du kannst aber andersrum, wenn du dich bewirbst, in der Bewerbung darum bitten, die Daten vertraulich zu behandeln, da du noch in einem Arbeitsverhältnis bist.
Davon gehe ich normalerweise auch aus, dass das jeder, den ich anschreibe, dann macht. Aber durch die technischen Gegebenheiten ist das viel einfacher möglich, vielleicht sowas dann eben zu verteilen.
Wäre natürlich unangenehm jetzt für deine jetzige Arbeitsverhältnis, wenn das bekannt würde, klar. Aber ich glaube natürlich, in Wirklichkeit musst du natürlich nicht begründen, warum du das nicht möchtest.
Ja, genau.
Und ich habe gedacht, wenn es irgendwie eine gangbare technische Möglichkeit gäbe, das für eine bestimmte Zeit nur einsehbar zu machen. Natürlich kann man es immer kopieren, vom Bildschirm, dem Screenshot, alles.
Das ist die Frage, die wir uns allgemein stellen. Das Problem, dass man gesellschaftliche Probleme nicht mit technischen Möglichkeiten oder Lösungen bearbeiten sollte.
Die Menschen müssen es entsprechend ausführen, sich an Rechte und Ordnung halten.
Du musst ein Grundbewusstsein für Datenschutz geschaffen werden. Das sind deine Daten. Du hast das Recht, über das Verteilen dieser Daten zu bestimmen.
Du musst ein Bewusstsein haben, dass du überhaupt Daten verteilst. Wenn dir Krümel aus der Jackentasche fallen, werden sie irgendwo auf der Straße liegen. Ich werde wissen, wo du warst.
Glaubst du, dass so ein Datenbrief, wie er jetzt vorgeschlagen wurde, eine Idee wäre, die auch die Unternehmen irgendwie incentiviert, dass sie die Daten freiwillig löschen, weil dann brauchen sie ja keine Datenbriefe raus schicken? Meinst du, das könnte was helfen?
Ja, die Frage ist natürlich auch, wer kontrolliert, dass jedes Unternehmen das wirklich dann auch macht.
Du bist nicht der Betroffene. Du kriegst ja Datenbriefe, wenn du keinen kriegst.
Wenn ich nicht kriege, dann könnte ich natürlich dem sagen, warum hast du mir keinen geschickt? Dann hätte der schon Ärger.
Das ist eine Frage der Strafen nicht, wenn die Strafen halt irgendwie ausreichend hoch angesetzt sind, wenn sie das nicht tun.
Das ist eh noch mal eine Sache, die wir hier natürlich nicht genügend angesprochen haben. Wir wünschen uns natürlich auch für die zukünftige Gesetzgebung einfach eine harte Sanktionierung, damit eben diese kavalierendste Leakgehabe auf...
Zu Hubs tut uns leid, ist passiert.
Das ist das, was man dann an Gewinnen auch daran hat.
Andreas, danke dir für den Einwand mit den Bewerbungen. Das hatten wir heute noch nicht in der Sendung. Danke schön.
Wir werden es mal verfolgen mit dem Datentrieb. Das ist eine interessante Idee.
Alles klar. Chaosradio auf Fritz, 0331 70 97 110. Wir reden heute über den Datenschutz für Arbeitnehmer. Also im günstigsten Fall für euch oder an eurer Uni oder wo ihr sonst irgendwie unterwegs seid. Bespitzelt, Belauscht, Abgeschnorchelt heißt die Sendung, wenn der Chef eure Mails mitliest und die Kamera beobachtet, wenn ihr aufs Klo geht. Der nächste am Telefon ist Daniel aus Berlin. Hallo Daniel, guten Abend.
Hallöchen.
Hallo. Wo arbeitest du oder was arbeitest du?
Also ich bin mittlerweile ganz woanders. Ich habe aber vor zwei Jahren noch in der Internetagentur gearbeitet und wir haben auch so ein bisschen Netzwerkbetreuung für Firmen gemacht. Und ich war da so als technischer Berater unterwegs und war dann halt bei dem einen Chef von der Firma, der dann gesagt hat, du, wir haben hier so einen Dienst und ich würde ganz gerne wissen, weil der Geld kostet, wie der denn von dem und den Mitarbeitern genutzt wird. Die hatten also so ein schönes Büronetzwerk, Einrichtungen mit festen IP-Adressen, wo man also auch ganz leicht per IP-Adresse den Arbeitsplatz zuweisen konnte. Und ich habe mir dann mal so Gedanken gemacht, wie viel eigentlich diese Sicherheitseinrichtungen, die wir da so implementiert haben, eigentlich an Daten sammelt und was man dann an alles sehen kann. Und im Prinzip interessiert sich da keiner für, es sei denn, es gibt ein Problem.
Das heißt, hast du die erst installiert oder dann nachgedacht?
Das Ding ist ja, das kommt dazu, man installiert halt Software, meistens dann natürlich auf dem Source-Bereich, weil es schön günstig ist. Und dann sind halt irgendwelche Pakete in der Standard-Konfiguration so ausgelegt, dass sie halt erstmal mitloggen. Und das, was man halt eben sieht, hat dann dem Auftraggeber, dem Chef sozusagen, dem Erteilungsleiter erstmal zeigen können. Also ich habe natürlich erstmal selber geguckt, bevor ich ihm irgendwas gezeigt habe. Und ich habe dann halt festgestellt, weil er wollte halt von seinem Arbeitsplatz und von zwei anderen das noch wissen, ob die diesen Dienst halt nutzen.
Und vom Computer seiner Frau vermutlich?
Nein, nein, nein. Nein, nein, das war in der Firma, nicht zu Hause. Aber wie ich dann halt gesehen habe, ist er dann halt auch nachts auf irgendwelchen oder abends auf irgendwelchen Porno-Seiten unterwegs gewesen.
Und das hat man nicht strafbar?
Nein, das ist nicht strafbar. Was mich dann erstmal zum Schmunzeln gebracht hat, wo ich ihn dann halt gefragt habe, ob er wirklich möchte, dass ich das sozusagen so mitlogge. Dass er das auswerten kann, weil man da eben auch Dinge sieht, die man vielleicht nicht sehen möchte.
Aber hey, das ist dann für eine Betriebsparty oder für ein Geburtstagsgeschenk für den Chef total praktisch.
Total praktisch. Was wir dann später in einem anderen Projekt gemacht haben, wo es um Anonymität geht, das heißt, wo wir eine Webseite oder ein Portal gebastelt haben, wo man sich also anonym beraten lassen kann, wo das halt ein Problem war, weil wir uns halt auch intensiv mit Datenschutz beschäftigt haben. Ansonsten, wenn man so eine Webseite aufbaut, dann ist da halt ein Apache Web Server, der hat halt einfach standardmäßig seine Logfiles, die halt mitlaufen, wo IP-Adressen mitgehalten werden, was man sich anguckt etc. Weil der Kunde will ja auch sehen, wer hat wo zugegriffen und wie viele Leute waren da und da ist so was natürlich eine IP-Adresse natürlich sehr hilfreich.
Aber ist ja schon ein Unterschied, ob der Kunde jetzt irgendwie, also ich sag nicht Bespitzelt, sondern ob der Betreiber jetzt was über das Kundenverhalten wissen will oder irgendwie das Verhalten der eigenen Mitarbeiter. Also ist halt schon deutlich konfigurierbar, das so einzustellen, dass halt genau diese Daten für Mitarbeiter nicht anfallen und ich meine, wenn du da technischer Berater warst, dann hättest du da irgendwie eigentlich irgendwie da deinen Senf zu abgeben können müssen.
Ja klar, in der Form, dass man halt sagen kann, also in dem Fall war es dann sogar relativ einfach. Der wollte dann, es war ein Dienst, der über FDP erreichbar war. Das heißt, da hätte man also ganz klar sagen können, okay, wir wollen diesen IP-Adressbereich über den und den Port, da wollen wir wissen, was da passiert, weil dann sieht man halt eben genau, was da kommt. Aber ich musste mir halt erstmal die ganzen Logfiles angucken, um überhaupt zu sehen, wo geht das genau hin und die entsprechenden Leute rausfiltern, um die es ging, sodass man also natürlich erstmal mit dem gesamten Logfall eben zu tun hat. Aber worum es mir eben geht, ist, also wir haben dann noch ein anderes Beispiel, eben für dieses Beratungsportal, tatsächlich den Apache von der Konstruktion her, also vom Logfall-Konstruktion anpassen müssen, damit er eben die IP-Adresse nicht mitschreibt, weil es ja hier um eben entsprechend anonymes Angebot ging.
Ja, aber das sollte halt eigentlich standardmäßig so betrieben werden. Also die Forderung ist ja irgendwie, Daten, die nicht wirklich sinnvoll oder nützlich sind, halt einfach gar nicht erst zu erheben. Und das heißt, wenn man halt so einen Apache aufsetzt, dann halt irgendwie gleich beim ersten Mal erst mal die Kommando-Zeitung, die die Option irgendwie rauskommentieren, dass halt diese Logs erst angelegt werden. Weil die braucht man normalerweise nicht. Beziehungsweise kann sie halt dann irgendwie einkompilieren, wenn sie halt wirklich zur Fehleranalyse oder sowas gebraucht werden.
Ich hab den Eindruck, dass deine Message eigentlich eher ist, dass man ja so diese Default-Einstellungen, von denen man manchmal gar nicht weiß. Genau. Ja, ist schon klar, was du sagen willst.
Ist natürlich ein guter Hinweis. Ich muss erstmal rein und muss es auskommentieren. Und für die meisten Betreiber ist es eigentlich irrelevant. Es gibt ja auch andere Möglichkeiten, um herauszukriegen, wie viele Leute meine Webseite besuchen. Und da gibt es eben zu wenig Hilfsmittel, um das eben auch sinnvoll umsetzen zu können. Weil letzten Endes ist es ja so, dass viele Leute jetzt sowas einsetzen, die eigentlich nicht so wirklich Ahnung davon haben. Und die froh sind, dass die Standardkonfiguration für sie schon so funktioniert.
Okay, aber normalerweise, wenn keiner auf die Daten zugräft, dann ist es ja auch nicht wirklich ein Problem.
Sie fallen ja aber trotzdem an. Begehrlichkeiten gibt es ja dann immer irgendwo.
Das ist mit der Schielerdatei ja letzten Endes auch so. Also wenn keiner auf die Daten zugräft, ist das ja eigentlich okay.
Ja, ich muss da sagen, ich muss da auf Starbuck jetzt mal direkt widersprechen. Also die Forderung ist ja schon lange. Und das gilt für Arbeitnehmerdaten, wie im Prinzip für jedes Apache Logging. Datensparsame Systeme sind einfach mal toll. Weil dann hat man nachher nicht den Ärger mit den Datenskandalen, wenn sie abhanden kommen. Man hat nicht den Ärger, wenn jemand plötzlich, und seit vor allem der Chef, der noch irgendwie weisungsbefugt ist, sagt, du ich werde da mal ran. Also man kann natürlich auch die eigenen Daten in dem Fall jetzt noch mitschützen, wenn man selber arbeitet. Also das klassische Win-win-win-win-situation.
Und alle sind glücklich. Auch Daniel, danke dir für den Anruf.
Ich finde den Hinweis auch sehr gut. Den sollten wir auf jeden Fall noch mal im Hinterkopf behalten, dass man eben darauf achtet und nicht so eben die Forderung immer so mitnimmt.
Danke Daniel, tschüss. Wir machen jetzt Nachrichten mit Wetter und Verkehr im Chaosradio. Danach geht es weiter unter anderem mit Tim, der was zum Thema Überwachung in Schulen von Schülern sagen will. Das wird spannend.
Für ihren großen Auftritt bei der Fritznacht der Talente.
Die Fritznacht der Talente.
Und wunderlichen Wortspielen.
Ich sag ich und ihr schreibt Loser. Was?
Ist... Das Publikum.
Wir.
Die Fripsnacht der Talente.
Zum sechsten Mal und im Großen Saal.
Format Miralspalast Berlin. Samstag.
21.
März.
Solang es doch Karten gibt, gibt es Karten überall, wo es Karten gibt.
Die sechste Fripsnacht der Talente.
Übertragen wir natürlich auch live und im Radio.
Und das wird. Mit Flip Burger. In Berlin sind neue schwere Fälle von Kindesmisshandlungen bekannt geworden. Seit gestern Abend musste die Polizei neun verwahrloste und verprügelte Kinder vor ihren Eltern retten und sie dem Kindernotdienst übergeben. Die Kinder waren zwischen zwei und dreizehn Jahre alt. Die Sprecherin des Kindernotdienstes Köhnen sagte der deutschen Presseagentur, alle ihre Häuser in Berlin seien voll. Nach einer Statistik mussten im letzten Jahr 2700 Kinder und Jugendliche eine Zeit lang bei Notdiensten unterkommen. Bei einem Flugzeugabsturz auf dem Amsterdamer Flughafen sind neun Menschen getötet worden. Rund 80 Passagiere wurden verletzt, davon 25 schwer. Die in Istanbul gestartete Maschine befand sich im Landeranflug, als sie auf einem Acker aufschlug und in drei Teile zerbrach. Die Unlucksursache gibt Rätsel auf, da kein Feuer ausbrach. Deshalb wird darüber spekuliert, ob in dem Flugzeug das Kerosin ausgegangen sein könnte. In Berlin haben Jugendliche gegen die Schülerdatei protestiert. Allerdings fiel die Demo deutlich kleiner aus als geplant. Die Initiative Bildungsblockaden einreißen hatte auf bis zu 1000 Teilnehmer gehofft. Es kamen weniger als 100. Die Schülerdatei kommt Mitte März. In ihr werden 16 Daten von jedem Berliner Schüler gespeichert, wie zum Beispiel Anschrift und Muttersprache. In kleinen Berliner Kneipen darf ab dem 1. Mai wieder geraucht werden. SPD und Linke unterschrieben den Entwurf für ein geändertes Nichtraucherschutzgesetz. Geraucht werden darf in solchen Raucherlokalen aber nur, wenn niemand unter 18 Jahren reinkommt und es keine Küche gibt, die frisches Essen serviert. Das Bundesverfassungsgericht hatte die Anti-Rauch-Gesetze von Berlin und Baden-Württemberg gekippt, deshalb mussten die Länder sie überarbeiten. In der Fußball-Champions League hat Bayern München auswärts bei Sporting Lissabon 5 zu 0 gewonnen. Das Rückspiel im Achtelfinale steigt am 10. März. In der Deutschen Eishockey-Liga haben die Berliner Eisbären gute Chancen, die Vorrunde zu gewinnen. Die Eisbären siegten im Nachholspiel gegen Adler Mannheim 7 zu 2. In der Tabelle führt Berlin jetzt 4 Punkte vor den Hannover Skorpions. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen Neuropin, Angermünde und Cottbus und Wittenberge und auch Frankfurt melden 4 Grad, Potsdam und Berlin 5 Grad. Heute Nacht sind dichte Wolken am Himmel. Ab Mitternacht kann es über dem Haveland und später dann überall in Berlin und Brandenburg kräftig regnen. Am Donnerstag bekommen wir neben einigen Schauern auch viel Wind und es wird 7 Grad kram. Keine Störungen von den Bundesstraßen und Autobahnen.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 103, 2, dann Fritz rund um Spremmen.
Blum, die Zeitsprechstunden.
Blum. Ihr seid auf Fritz im Chaos Radio Nummer 143. Willkommen. Starbuck ist hier, Konstanz ist hier von Chaos Computer Club. Mein Name ist Jakob Kranze. Wir reden heute über Datenschutz für Arbeitnehmer und drehen das Ganze jetzt ein bisschen runter. Wir haben viel über Betriebe geredet und über Firmen. Jetzt reden wir mal über die Schulen, weil Tim ist am Telefon. Hallo Tim, grüß dich.
Wo gehst du zur Schule?
Und wie ist es bei euch? Gibt es da auch schon Verdachtsmomente, dass ihr abgeschnüffelt werdet?
Ja, ich hole jetzt mal aus. Wir haben jetzt seit zwei Jahren einen neuen Informatiklehrer an der Schule, der dann auch mal direkt, als er angefangen ist, hat sich mal ein schönes Netzwerk aufgebaut und auch mal ein schönes WLAN. Ja, und wie das halt so ist, man geht mit seinem Laptop in die Schule, hat dort ein WLAN, das muss natürlich dann erst mal schön geklackt werden, weil man möchte ja auch in den Freistunden mal ein bisschen surfen dürfen.
Ein verständliches Begehr.
Ja, natürlich. Und dann kam auf einmal, also der Informatiklehrer hat sich so einen kleinen, kleines Räumchen eingerichtet, wo an seinem Haupt-PC, eine Abschnorchel-Büro-Tür zum Abschließen. Ja, ungefähr, wo er dann ein PC hat mit vier Monitoren, wo er dann den kompletten Inhalt alleine der Interneträume sieht. Plus noch ein Ding, wo einfach nur die Konsolenfenster auf sind, wo er sieht, welcher Traffic wo langgeht, von den ganzen IPs her.
Alles niffen, ja?
Ja, und wir haben jetzt auch noch schöne E-Mails von der Schule, die da natürlich viel schöner aussehen als solche Web-DE-Adressen.
Ach so, als E-Mail-Adresse verstehe, ja.
Und man wird ja jetzt auch vor den Lehren immer geraten, man sollte bitte doch die benutzen bei irgendwelchen Bewerbungen.
Habt ihr noch keine E-Mail-Verschlüsselung?
Doch, aber die werden halt da... Nee, oder? Nee, ist sogar ohne Verschlüsselung.
Muss man mal, muss man sich mal klicken, aber...
Aber immer im einem App benutzt auch. Also die Daten bleiben schön noch drauf.
Das hilft nicht für den Inhalt, der mir... Das heißt, dein Verdacht ist, dass der leichte, voyeuristisch veranlagt ist oder einfach ein erhöhtes Kontrollbedürfnis hat?
Also ist das nur ein Verdacht, oder?
Nee, man hat ihn ein paar Mal geärgert und irgendwie hat er dann angefangen total zufrieden zu werden und hat dann angefangen damit und es hat schon ein paar Leute schon gesehen. Man stand da schon mal hinter ihm, als man den ganzen Traffic dort gesehen hat.
Aber ist das nicht auch, wir hatten ja vorhin die Geschichte aus der IT-Firma, ist das nicht auch was, womit man zum Vertrauenslehrer oder im Zweifelsfall zum Direktor geht und sagt, Herr So-und-So, wir glauben, dass der Kollege Informatik-Lehrer da Dinge tut, die wir nicht lustig finden, können wir mal zu einer Aussprache bitten?
Ja, aber ich glaube so, wenn der Direktor ist, geht so gut auf die 60.
Er muss ja gar nicht Ahnung haben. Er muss ja einfach nur wissen, dass ihr ein Problem mit einem bestimmten Lehrer habt und dass es da eine Aussprache gibt. Dass der Direktor nicht wissen muss, wo man die Lokfels findet, das finde ich jetzt nicht so dramatisch. Aber er ist der Chef von deinem Informatik-Lehrer.
Ja, na klütt, natürlich, aber er will ja jetzt auch nicht wirklich, dass wir da die ganze Zeit nur irgendwelche Blödsinn machen.
Das ist ja eine ganz allgemeine Frage. Es geht ja nicht darum, was ihr wirklich tut, sondern es geht darum, dass ein Lehrer unerlaubterweise tatsächlich in den Datenstrom irgendwie einen Blick hat. Also ganz unabhängig davon, was halt wirklich in den Datenstrom drin ist, ist das einfach mal illegal und irgendwie, deswegen sollte euer Weg auf jeden Fall zum Vertrauenslehrer erstmal gehen oder irgendwie dann direkt zum Direktor.
Oder zum Elternbeirat oder wer auch immer da zuständig ist, um das dann ähnlich wie bei den großen Firmen über Datenschutzbeauftragten erstmal zu klären. Weil dich hinzustellen und zu sagen, ich finde das alles doof, das ändert ja nicht. Was habt ihr dagegen unternommen?
Wir haben uns jetzt bei uns in der Stufe zusammengelegt und uns einen schönen UMTS-Stick gekauft. Wir haben jetzt immer so ein paar Leute, der Stick liegt direkt bei uns. Wir haben im Keller noch einen kleinen Proberaum, der von ein paar Leuten benutzt wird. Und der liegt jetzt dort immer. Und es gibt so ein paar Leute, die sich ein bisschen auskennen und die haben jetzt mal das UMTS-Internet offen.
Na gut, aber da ist natürlich die Geschwindigkeit ein bisschen lame, wenn das sehr viele Leute nutzen.
Ja, unabhängig davon. Ihr habt ja schon irgendwo auch die Pflicht, den Leuten, die nicht so auskennen, zu vermitteln, dass es da ein Problem gibt, bzw. direkt auch was gegen das Problem zu tun. Und nicht eure eigene Sache zu machen und euch dann gemütlich in die Ecke zu setzen und selber braun zu klicken.
Ja, ich finde auch. Also ist schon so, dass ihr da auch Verantwortung habt für eure Mitschüler.
Also in der SV haben wir es schon ein bisschen umgetreten, dass wir jetzt hier so ein paar Sticks verteilen werden. Und es läuft auch mehr oder weniger.
Ihr könntet aber auch mal rumtreten in der SV, dass ihr da zu einer Aussprache mit dem Lehrer kommen wollt.
Ja, es wird auch noch nebenbei gemacht.
Ich meine, man muss halt einfach mal ganz klar sagen, wie das er sich dort illegal verhält. Das ist irgendwie ein Fakt. Und jetzt irgendwie da außen rum zu manövrieren, ist zwar für euch vielleicht ganz nett und gut und schön, aber...
Aus sportlicher Sicht betrachtet auch Kompliment. So, einfach einen anderen Weg gewählt, aber es löst das Problem noch nicht.
Ja, aber das Problem ist ja, dass gerade diese Überwachungsprogramme in Informatikräubern, die sind auch schon... Also das, was ich jetzt auch von anderen Schulen bei uns in der Gegend kenne, das sind die einfach auch in der Tagesordnung.
Aber das macht es doch nicht wirklich besser. Ich meine, genau deswegen, weil die halt überall sind, müsstet ihr irgendwie einfach mal jetzt anfangen und das irgendwie dann im Zweifel auch irgendwie an die große Glocke hängen.
Ja, und wenn es bei eurer Schule ist, und es gibt noch mehrere Schulen im Umkreis, dann kannst du die anderen Schülervertretungen auch rufen und kannst wunderbar mit 1.000, 2.000, 3.000 Schülern dich an die zuständigen Direktoren wenden und kannst sagen, so nicht.
Aber hat da bisher noch keiner irgendwie angefangen?
Ja, mach doch mal.
Bei den Informatikräumen...
Na, was das denn für eine Ausrede?
Komm mal, Tim, du bist jetzt gefordert.
Ich frage jetzt einfach nur gerade so, weil das...
Das ist schon klar, also das ist natürlich nicht einfach.
War mir bisher noch nicht so bekannt, dass es in den Informatikräumen... Ist mir jetzt gerade so eingefallen, dass da auch dieses nette Programm drauf ist.
Ja, dann mach doch mal am Bude, ihr habt doch sicher auch eine Schülerzeitung, wo man das mal schreiben kann, ihr habt ein schwarzes Brett, wo man es anlageln kann.
Man muss natürlich ein bisschen auseinanderhalten. Ihr habt natürlich als Schüler gewisse Rechte, dieses Netz zu benutzen, etwa zur Kommunikation, zur Informationsgewinnung. Eine andere Sache ist, wenn natürlich ein Informatiklehrer in seinem Unterricht sicherstellt, dass ihr etwa nicht im Informatikunterricht surft, weil er das unterbinden will, das kann er tun.
Gerade Quake Live mal ausprobieren, was er als Browser geht.
Genau, er kann Chat unterbinden, wenn er will.
Das ist aber ein Unterschied, ob man es unterbindet oder ob man überwacht, was geklickt hat.
Aber auch in Freistunden sind diese Räume offen. Man hat den Output von dem Monitor.
Also die Aussage ist ganz klar, es geht Ihnen überhaupt gar nichts an, was ihr da tut, während eurer Freizeit, während eurer Freistunden. Wenn er da Programme installiert, dann ist das rechtswidrig gewesen und dann hat er es gefälligst zu unterlassen.
Denn auch das Fernmeldegeheimnis, das würde ja hier betroffen sein, zumindest bei den E-Mails, ist natürlich auch für Minderjährige, für Schüler, für alle. Also wert euch mal.
Ich glaube, du hast einen Termin beim Schülersprecher und bei der Schülervertretung und bei der Elternvertretung und demnächst ist der Direktor dein neuer Freund.
Und wir hätten gerne die Ergebnisse, die du da irgendwie da herausziehst, irgendwie als kleinen Artikel an die Datensteuerer geschickt. Das ist einfach ein Thema, was wirklich viele Leute interessiert. Und wenn du irgendwie da Ergebnisse zu hast, dann irgendwie einen kurzen Text, so irgendwie 5000 Zeichen oder sowas, ds.ed. ccc.de und wir freuen uns und drucken das dann auch garantiert ab. Super Tim, vielen Dank.
Eigentlich führt der Weg dann aber wirklich über den Direktor, ne?
Unterschiedlich, also wenn man natürlich jetzt irgendwie weiß, es kann ja mal dieselbe Person sein, gibt's ja auch, aber wenn man weiß, dass man da wenig Chancen hat, wenn man etwa seinen Direktor schon kennt, man kann auch noch eine Etage höher gehen, nämlich zum Landesratenschutzbeauftragten, kann man natürlich machen.
Wenn man eine gute Elternvertretung hat.
Elternvertretung, Schülervertretung, da gibt's halt wirklich viele Ansprechpartner.
Man darf halt nicht über 10 hinaus schießen. Man muss halt sehen, sich vorher ein bisschen kundig machen. Da hilft zum Beispiel, wenn man den Landesratenschutzbeauftragten mal fragt. Die geben nämlich auch Rechtsauskünfte.
Hallo Stefan, guten Abend. Hallo, wo arbeitest du?
Ich mache Mitarbeiterbefragung zum Thema Arbeitsklima. Allerdings, das Thema, die Story, die ich hier zum Besten geben will, ist ein paar Jahre her.
Da habe ich noch etwas ganz anderes gemacht.
Ach schade, ist ja interessant. Na gut, erzähl mal.
Ja, Mitarbeiterfragen, können wir später noch dazu kommen. Heute ist ja das Bewusstsein, das merken wir auch, wenn wir Mitarbeiter befragen zu einem eigentlich positiven Thema, sehr groß und Überwachung ist sehr wohl ein Thema und beeinflusst auch sehr wohl das Verhalten von Menschen an den Arbeitsplätzen.
Das macht mich aber echt total glücklich. Da würde ich gerne mal die Ergebnisse nachher noch hören, aber erzähl mal erstmal deinen Freund.
Ja, www.betriebsklima.de, kannste mal gucken. So, jetzt aber die Story. Die ist ungefähr neun bis zehn Jahre her. Zu der Zeit war das alles noch überhaupt kein Thema. Folgender Sachverhalt, ein guter Freund von mir, damals Manager unterer Ebene bei einem internen IT-Dienstleister einer großen Versicherung, war mit dem Problem konfrontiert, dass bei ihm ständig in der Abteilung Hardware geklaut wurde. Und zwar ziemlich hässlich, sodass die Kollegen auch wirklich mit Datenverlust zu kämpfen hatten. War ja damals alles noch etwas ne andere Technik. Wenn halt mal ne Festplatte geklaut war, dann war das mit dem Backup schon mal so ne Sache. Und man konnte dem Dieb nicht auf die Schliche kommen. Und die ganze Atmosphäre war vergiftet. Ist das ein Kollege, ist das einer vom Wachstum usw. Kurz und gut.
Jeder misstraut jedem.
Jeder misstraut jedem. So, er hat dann, wie ich später herausstelle, einen schweren Fehler begangen. Er hat nämlich zusammen mit zwei ihm vertrauenswürdig erscheinenden Mitarbeitern heimlich Kameras installieren lassen, die damals noch mit sehr schlechter Auflösung sozusagen so einen kleinen Stream aufgezeichnet haben, um den oder die Diebe zu überführen. Da wusste also niemand vorn außer diesen Manager und seinen zwei Mitarbeitern. Die haben das auch geschafft zum Leidwesen aller. Es war ein Kollege. Diesen Kollegen haben sie zur Rede gestellt. Und wie gesagt, waren keine Kleinigkeiten an Diebstellen, sondern schon richtig fett. Die Sache konnte auch nicht unter der Decke gehalten werden. Also dieser Kollege wurde gekündigt. Auch unter allgemeinem Beifall fand auch jeder richtig. So, jetzt komme ich ins Spiel. Ich hatte dann meinen Freund dann zu beraten, denn diese Aktion hatte für ihn übelste arbeitsrechtliche Konsequenzen. Der Arbeitnehmer wollte ihn ganz konkret deswegen kündigen. Das konnte dann unter tätigem Einsatz der Kollegen und des Betriebsrates, man höre uns staunen, also der Betriebsrat musste sozusagen dafür kämpfen, dass ein heimlicher Überwacher nicht gefeuert wird, konnte dann abgewendet werden, aber es war nicht sehr schön. Also von Gehaltskürzung über Strafversetzung, also you name it, hat der Mann reichlich Probleme gehabt und hat sich auch ziemlich schlecht hinterher gefühlt. So nach dem Wort, ich mache hier einen guten Einsatz für alle und kriege dafür noch eins auf den Deckel.
Nicht nur das, das Recht war ja in diesem Fall auch ganz klar auf seiner Seite.
Da sind wir wieder am Anfang mit dem Verdachtsmoment.
Ja, ja, ich höre die Frage, das Recht war ganz klar auf seiner Seite. Damals war das eben alles noch nicht so klar. Und hätte nicht sein Betriebsrat und seine Kollegen, vor allem seine Mitarbeiter, hätten die nicht sehr stark für ihn Partei ergriffen, dann wäre das für ihn übel ausgegangen. Und da ist natürlich auch, vor allem dann auch intern, die ganze Frage Datenschutz, Privatsphäre ziemlich diskreditiert worden. Das verstand natürlich keiner, dass sowas nicht in Ordnung sein sollte.
Also das Urteil dazu, ich hätte das vorhin schon mal besprochen, mit der Videoüberwachung, ist tatsächlich schon von 2004. Aber das hat sich natürlich auch, ja okay, aber es spricht sich auch nur ein bisschen langsamer rum, kommt noch dazu.
Also das Problem ist halt einfach, dass er, wie gesagt, dass er den Betriebsrat bzw. die zuständigen Stellen informiert hätte, dann wäre das halt rechtlich abgesichert gewesen. Und wenn er es halt nicht mit dem Betriebsrat abstimmt, dann hat er einfach mal illegal gehandelt. Das ist halt nichts von der Hand zu weisen. Das mag zwar zum Ergebnis geführt haben, aber er hat sich einfach nicht an die Sachen gehalten. Und ich meine, gut, in dem Fall haben sie jetzt den Dieb gefunden, aber sie haben trotzdem halt massiv die Rechte der anderen Mitarbeiter in dem Fall beeinträchtigt.
Naja, wie gesagt, ein konkreter Verdacht lag vor, dann ist das doch okay für einen begrenzten Zeitraum.
Ja, wenn man den Betriebsrat informiert. Und wenn er das getan hätte, dann hätte er auch keinen Ärger gekriegt.
Hinterher ist man immer schlauer. Wie gesagt, es kam diese extreme Misstrauensituation dazu. Und die Sorge, dass der Betriebsrat nicht so ganz dicht hält, da spielen dann ja auch menschliche Beziehungen zwischen Leuten, die so ein Drittel ihres Lebens miteinander verbringen.
Das mag ja alles richtig sein, aber trotzdem kann man sich ja deswegen nicht über Gesetze hinwegsetzen, nur weil man genau solche Befürchtungen hat.
Heute ist die Sache einigermaßen klar. Ich wollte mir mal zum Besten geben, dass diese Entwicklung oder das, was heute zum Teil aufliegt, möglicherweise seine Wurzeln in Zeiten hat, als das Bewusstsein noch ein anderes war. Und dass wir vielleicht gerade erleben, wie mit einem erheblichen Timelag, wie das bei Menschen immer so ist, da eine Bewusstseinsänderung stattfindet.
Das ist natürlich ein guter Hinweis. Mich freut ohnehin, dass du das sozusagen diagnostiziert hast, dass sich da viel verändert hat. Weil ich glaube auch nicht, dass wir weiterkommen, wenn nicht auch die Leute, also der Durchschnittsarbeitnehmer, sagen wir mal dafür, genauso wie der Durchschnittsbürger, ein Gefühl hat. Jetzt sag doch mal das Ergebnis von deiner Arbeit.
Also wir machen anonyme und wie ich meine datenschutzrechtlich äußerst vorbildliche Mitarbeiterbefragung zum Thema Arbeitsklima in allen möglichen Organisationen.
Wenn ich das in der Zwischenzeit richtig gesehen habe, seid ihr so eine Art Unternehmensberatung?
Ja, wir machen das neben sozusagen das Ehrenamtlichprojekt nebenbei, dass auch Wissenschaftler dabei, eine Hochschule dabei, eine Gewerkschaft, ein Arbeitgeberverband, also was.
Also die Juden.
Ja, davon muss man aber natürlich erst mal die Leute überzeugen. Es ist keineswegs so, dass wir überall offene Türen einrennen. Die Arbeitnehmer, wenn sie begriffen, da worum es geht, finden das zwar sehr gut und auch Betriebsräte helfen uns da. Und auch viele Arbeitgeber haben eingesehen, dass das ja auch für die Produktivität und alles eine wirklich gute Sache ist, ein gutes Arbeitsklima. Aber bis wir es wirklich schaffen, dass so 70, 80, 90 Prozent der Leute mitmachen, was sehr viel ist bei solchen Befragungen. Häufig ist das leider völlig umgekehrt und es werden ziemlich unzulässige Flüsse gezogen aus sowas.
Man fragt vier Leute und dann...
Unglaublich. Und dafür werden dann eine rasende Menge Geld in den Rechen gesetzt.
Okay, aber jetzt mal zurück zu den Ergebnissen.
Also Bewusstsein ist da. Die Problematik liegt oft eher in der Management-Ebene. So ein Thema ist halt hochpolitisch. Also es ist eher die Angst da. Und ein Manager oder ein Betriebsrat oder beides, wenn sie sowas machen wollen, brauchen also, das erleben wir immer wieder, ein rundes Dreivierteljahr, um politisch intern abzusichern, ob man denn sowas machen kann.
Okay, das ist aber erstmal ein gutes Zeichen, dass man eben erst nachdenkt, abwägt und für und wieder irgendwie gegeneinander stellt. Das halte ich für eine wichtige Sache.
Also es tut sich fast, in jeder Hinsicht. Und ich sage das auch den Leuten, die so ein bisschen frustriert, dann immer zurück und sagen, die haben sich immer noch nicht entschieden, die wissen nicht, das ist doch eigentlich gut. Also auf ziemlich breiter Front ist da ein Bewusstsein da. Allerdings gibt es auch viel, viel Angst. Es gibt nicht nur dieses Positive, was machen die da neugierig, sondern schlichte Angst. Es kommt auch immer wieder vor, dass wir Fragebögen kriegen. Die Mitarbeiter haben also auch die Möglichkeit, uns die direkt zuzuschicken, falls sie irgendwie ihren Betrieb da nicht trauen. Auch wenn die anonymen sind, die sind nicht mal mit handschriftlichen Kreuzen, sondern mit einer Schreibmaschine ausgefüllt. Also fortvollkommene Paranoia.
Kannst du mal ein bisschen näher darauf eingehen, was ihr da so für Fragen stellt? Also worum geht es überhaupt?
Wir stellen Fragen, die darauf abzielen, festzustellen, wie arbeiten Leute eigentlich zusammen? Woher wissen sie, ob sie ihre Arbeit gut oder schlecht machen? Kriegen sie überhaupt Feedback? Vertrauensfragen, eben auch so etwas, Überwachung spielt da eine Rolle. Ist ein standardisierter Fragebogen, sozialwissenschaftliches, anonymes Verfahren. Also nicht unbedingt Rocket Science, aber halt in dieser Breite, nämlich in Deutschland sehr sehr ungewöhnlich. Und der Witz ist, das Ganze basiert auf dem Benchmarking. Also es nützt ja überhaupt nichts, wenn jemand sagt, das ist gut, mittel, gut oder schlecht oder Schulnote 1 bis 6. Sondern ob eine Schulnote 3 gut oder schlecht ist, dazu muss man wissen, was für einen Arbeitsplatz man befragt.
Das heißt, wenn man jetzt sagt, so ein Misstrauen in Bezug auf Datenschutz, kann er eben dazu führen, dass das Betriebsklima insgesamt viel schlechter wird. Ist das so eine Aussage, die ihr daraus gewinnen könnt?
Ja, man kann ganz deutlich sehen, in dem konkreten Fall, das Beste wäre gewesen, wenn es hier Wohlüberwachung gibt. Aber wenn das auch jedem bekannt ist und auch klar kommuniziert ist, wo findet die Stadt, wie findet die Stadt, wer hat darauf Zugriff und so weiter. Also Offenheit ist da ein Thema.
Das sind so die allgemeinen Aussagen, die getroffen werden von den Mitarbeitern. Also dass sie halt schon gerne überwacht werden wollen.
Vorsicht, dafür geben unsere Untersuchungen keinen Beleg. Da muss man aufpassen, die Statistik kann auch nicht alles beantworten. Ich will damit nur sagen, wenn jemand sagt, wir machen sowas gar nicht und es gibt überhaupt keine Information, dann ist das schlechter, als wenn jemand sagt, es gibt Überwachung und zwar da und da.
Kriegt ihr denn auch im Rücklauf, wie eure Ergebnisse weiterverwendet wurden in den Betrieben, also irgendwie, wie die umgesetzt wurden?
Das ist vom Betrieb zu Betrieb sehr verschieden. Das bestimmt natürlich der Betriebsrat, das Management, die dort Beteiligten, auch mal der Datenschutzbeauftragte, sowieso es eingibt. Das ist sehr, sehr verschieden. Und da müssen wir auch respektieren, was die Leute da im Betrieb jeweils wollen. Also höchst unterschiedlich.
Na, vielleicht magst du uns noch mal eine Mail schreiben an chaosradio.ccc.de. Vielleicht können wir da noch mal in Kontakt bleiben. Ich glaube, das würde uns noch ein bisschen genauer interessieren.
Großes Interesse auf allen Seiten.
Alles klar, ja schicke ich mal los.
Ich habe noch eine Frage. Gehen die Daten jetzt wirklich nur an die Betriebe selber wieder? Oder wertet die noch anderweitig aus? Also in Form von Studien, so allgemeinen Studien?
Nee, das machen wir nicht. Das Einzige, worauf das Ganze basiert, wir schreiben mit den Daten unsere Benchmarks vor. Wir gucken also, wir haben einen Arbeitsplatz, wo Leute in der großen, zugigen Werkhalle große, schwere Maschinen zusammenbauen. Ob das dann Baggerlogomotiven oder Panzer sind, spielt keine Rolle. Das sind dann vergleichbare Arbeitsplätze. Mehr machen wir nicht. Und das ist, glaube ich, auch ganz wichtig. Also sonst würden, wenn wir da nicht glaubwürdig wären, dann wären die Rücklaufquoten sicherlich schlechter.
Aber man könnte ja gleich sagen, wie das die Ergebnisse anonymen für weitere Studien zur Verfügung gestellt wären. Also ich meine, es wäre schon interessant, auch mal die Ergebnisse unabhängig von dem Betrieb selber, sondern halt wirklich eingegrenzt auf Produktion oder Dienstleistung auch mal die Ergebnisse anderweitig aufgearbeitet zu sehen.
Ja, unsere Wissenschaftler bei uns in der Initiative sagen, da sind wir noch nicht weit genug, da müssen wir noch ein paar Daten sammeln. Dass das in einer einen oder anderen Dissertation irgendwann mal verwurstet wird.
Um ein Fazit zu finden, das bleibt spannend.
Wo du gerade sagst, Daten sammeln, das heißt, ihr bewahrt die Ergebnisse dann doch schon auf, oder?
Nein, es sind also keine personenbezogenen Daten. Und zum anderen wird auch nicht aufbewahrt, wie viele Antworten wir haben. Wir bewahren lediglich die unterschiedlichen Indizes, die Benchmarks auf.
Ja genau, richtig vorbildlich.
Das allerdings ist nicht unbedingt ein Marketingargument, weil die meisten Leute das einfach nicht begreifen, worin die Vorbildlichkeit liegt.
Das heißt, es bleibt noch viel zu tun. Danke dir, Stefan.
Es bleibt noch viel zu tun.
Uns läuft ein kleines bisschen die Zeit weg jetzt. Ich verstehe, dass du das total spannend findest, aber wir haben noch ein bisschen was zu erzählen. Außerdem kommt auch gleich Tobi Koch mit dem Night Flight. Wir fassen mal so ein bisschen zusammen, das Chaosradio von heute ist 143 zum Thema Datenschutz für Arbeitnehmer. Ich würde sagen, es gibt auf jeden Fall ein Bewusstsein. Viele Leute machen sich Sorgen und denken auch ernsthaft drüber nach, ist das, was jetzt hier in meinem Umfeld passiert, ist das schon eine Beschnüfflung oder ist es irgendwie noch okay, was der Chef so macht? Also das ist da. Was nicht da ist, ist eine geregelte rechtliche Grundlage, weil sich der und die Gesetzgeber da immer wieder fein mal drum drücken. So was zu tun und so wie es im Moment aussieht, wird es in dieser Legislaturperiode auch nicht mehr passieren.
Ja, da hat der Herr Minister Schäuble den lustigen Satz gesagt, also einen Schnellschuss machen wir jetzt nicht mehr. Wir sollten halt mal überlegen, was wollen wir denn eigentlich drin haben in diesem Gesetz? Also ich denke, es hat sich aus der Sendung und ganz gut herauskristallisiert, was wir fordern wollen. Das eine ist, was jetzt schon mehrfach angesprochen wurde, wir müssen bessere Rechte haben für Betriebsräte und für betriebliche Datenschutzbeauftragte. Das ist eine wichtige Sache. Wir brauchen eine ganz klare Regelung für die Videoüberwachung, eine restriktive Regelung, das ist vollkommen klar. Wir brauchen eine übersichtliche Regelung für Internet- und Mailüberwachung. Wir haben gesehen, dass wir die Bereiche sind, wo viele drüber reden. Klar, wir brauchen viel strengere Regeln für die Weitergabe von Personalräten, auch etwa bei Versetzungen oder in Konzernen, sodass die Arbeitnehmer und aber auch die Bewerber, haben wir auch gehört, konkret zustimmen müssen. Das finde ich sehr wichtig. Und wir brauchen ein Verbot von diesen Gentests, auch wenn sie freiwillig sind. Das finde ich auch sehr wichtig. Und wir müssen noch etwas fordern. Ich finde, dass die betrieblichen Datenschutzbeauftragten genauso wie Betriebsräte teilweise in ihrer Arbeitszeit für diese Arbeit freigestellt werden. Denn wir haben gesehen, die machen offenbar noch nicht genug. Und das tun sie deshalb nicht, weil sie nicht genug Zeit freigestellt bekommen. Also ich glaube, das sind so die wesentlichen Forderungen. Die sind teilweise Jahre alt. Jetzt müssen die mal kommen. Aber ich bin wieder zu Kämpfer, soll ich die Klappe halten?
Nein, nein, alles gut, alles gut. Also ihr seht, es bleibt noch eine Menge zu tun. Das Chaosradio für heute schließt die Pforten. Ihr könnt es noch mal nachhören auf chaosradio.ccc.de Ja, Starbuck, alles gut. Lass mich doch erstmal kurz meinen Sermon machen. chaosradio.ccc.de, da gibt es den Podcast. Da gibt es auch Chaosradio Express mit noch mehr Technik, Geek, Nerd, Wahnsinn, den ihr gerne haben möchtet. Fritz.de klicken, da steht die Playlist zur Sendung. Und ansonsten sei noch auf ccc.de verwiesen, denn da gibt es die anstehenden nächsten Termine, unter anderem die SIG-Imte, die stattfindet in Köln vom 22.24.Mai und den Datengarten Starbuck.
Ich wollte dir den ganzen Wort verlegen, ich wollte nur Konstanz darauf hinweisen, dass sie das noch in die Suche haben.
Ja, weil ich so vergessen bin. Wir haben nämlich wieder einen Datengarten, der 30. ein Jubiläum und der steht unter dem Motto Hack the System und Friedemann kommt und erzählt uns mal ein bisschen von einem Projekt, was OpenLoco heißt. Wir machen uns einfach mal keinen Gedanken um diesen seltsamen Namen. Aber es geht ein bisschen darüber, wie man Interessen durchsetzt gegenüber Politik und Wirtschaft. Also, das ist am 26. Februar, um 8.00 Uhr. Also morgen.
In den Klubräumen, also in den Berliner Klubräumen, das ist Marienstrasse 11, im Hinterhaus. In Mitte.
Also eigentlich ist das heute, fast.
Na ja, in drei Minuten.
Ihr könnt im Prinzip gleich hinfahren und warten.
Allklar.
Genau, das sollten wir noch sagen.
Das war das Chaosradio mit Constanze Starbuck. Mein Name ist Jakob Kranz. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören, fürs Mitmachen. Weiter diskutieren geht natürlich auch auf chaosradio.ccc.de. Hier geht es weiter mit Tobi Koch und dem Night Flight. Und wenn alles gut geht, haben wir jetzt schon ein Thema für die nächste Sendung. Dann wird es nämlich, wenn alles so geplant ist, wie es läuft, um Datenrettung gehen. Wann habe ich eigentlich den letzten Backup gemacht?
Das frag dich mal. Denken wir auch mal zu den Hörern.
Denk mal drüber nach. Bis zum nächsten Mal.